good grammar isn't just a way to sound
professional or feel morally superior in
all those facebook debates
the best way to feel superior is to not
participate in facebook debates at all
but as american writer robert brault
once quipped do not be surprised when
those who ignore the rules of grammar
also ignore the law
after all the law is just so much
grammar so in answer to the question
who gives a [ __ ] about the oxford comma
well
i do and so do most lawyers matters of
grammar syntax and yes even a misplaced
comma
have changed the course of history on
more than one occasion a poorly placed
comma has cost the us government and
businesses millions of dollars other
times
comma placement has literally cost
people their lives
such was the case of sir roger caseman
an irish separatist convicted of treason
in great britain during world war one
who
famously is said to have been quote
hanged on a comma but
more on that later now i know what
you're thinking isn't this video just
like a half as interesting video
to which i say no it's like five half as
interesting videos
crammed together sue me
brought to you by audible let's start
off with a case of the two million
dollar
comma few days inspire more anger and
frustration here in the united states
than april 15th
tax day
[Music]
but federal income taxes as we know them
today have only existed since the early
20th century following the ratification
of the 16th amendment
before that the u.s government funded
its operations a bit differently and on
july 4th 1789 president george
washington signed the tariff act of 1789
stipulating that
duties would be laid on quote goods
wares and merchandise in order to quote
support the government instead of taxing
income the government taxed imported
goods to fund its priorities now you may
know these as
tariffs and contrary to what president
trump says
sorry former president trump man that
feels kind of good now uh where was i oh
yes uh
contrary to what former president trump
would say tariffs are not paid by
foreign companies or
china tariffs are taxes on imported
foreign goods paid by
americans and for over a century after
our country's founding
these foreign import tariffs served as
the primary source of the us
government's revenue at times accounting
for as much as 95 percent of the federal
budget and for an eight year period
beginning in 1862 the us government
briefly levied income taxes as part of a
patriotic war effort to support the
union effort against the confederacy but
after the civil war the u.s returned to
using tariffs to fund the majority of
government operations
so enter president ulysses s grant who
signed the tariff
act of 1872 which sought to ease the
burden on the economy by exempting a
variety of goods from tariffs and that
brings us to how one typo cost the us
government 2 million
or approximately 42 million dollars in
today's dollars
and quick aside since we're talking
about typos and commas
grant was actually born hiram ulysses
grant but he owes his name ulysses s
grant to a typo when a congressman
nominated grant to become a candidate
for west point military academy due to a
typo he accidentally recommended
ulysses s grant and when grant got to
west point he registered as ulysses
hiram
grant likely due to concern of being
made fun of for having his initials
spelled h-u-g
yeah the guy likes a hug but eventually
he started going by ulysses s grant like
i said
typos can literally change the course of
history but
back to what you all came here for
hardcore typographical syntax
and a history lesson on u.s tariff laws
now all prior tariff acts had included a
list of goods that were generally exempt
from being taxed upon importation to the
united states
among these exempt items were quote
fruit plants tropical and semi-tropical
for the purpose of propagation or
cultivation
notice fruit plants refers to the plants
not the fruit itself
buying fruit used to be quite expensive
the 1870 tariff act levied a duty of 20
on oranges lemons pineapples and grapes
and a duty of 10 on limes bananas
and essentially all other fruit fruit
was a very popular import item and thus
fruit tariffs represented a not in
substantial portion of the federal
budget and in the 1872 tariff act
revision there was a rather unfortunate
and
costly drafting error the list of
exemptions in the 1872 tariff act was
supposed to read
fruit hyphen plants with a hyphen in
between but instead the statute read
fruit
comma plants so with fruit comma plants
replacing fruit
hyphen plants again i don't know how we
can cover such a
sexy sexy topic as this i do what i want
the importers argue that the act of 1872
now allowed free entry of all tropical
and semi-tropical fruits
filing refund claims from the us
government immediately upon arrival of
fruit shipments the secretary of the
treasury initially rejected this claim
arguing that the grammatical error was
clearly intended to read otherwise
importers hoping to take advantage of
this loophole filed a series of lawsuits
and
once it was clear that the treasury
department's arguments would not hold up
in court
the treasury relented and in december
1874
two years after the unfortunate typo the
us government agreed that imported
fruits were tax-free
under the 1872 act and all taxes
collected on imported fruit
was refunded two million dollars worth
that typo would end up costing the us
government two million dollars in
revenue which was approximately 42
million dollars in 2021
and that represented 1.3 percent of the
entire government's total tariff income
and 0.65 of the entire federal budget
needless to say
this case was bananas now there are
certain topics that you just
simply don't talk about in polite
company religion politics
money but not even these topics are as
polarizing as the oxford comma
which ended up costing one main dairy
company five million dollars
and if you see someone who is not using
an oxford comma
please call 9-1-1 that monster has to be
reported to the authorities
so what is an oxford comma well in a
list of three or more items such as
lions tigers and bears
oh my those who ascribe to the oxford
comma rule would place a comma after
tigers while others would simply write
lions tigers and bears
without the second comma and apparently
the internet is very very divided on the
oxford comma half of the internet
likes to be wrong what would you do with
the brain if you had one
so why does the oxford comma matter well
the presence or absence of the oxford
comma can completely change the meaning
of a sentence for example if i say for
my birthday i went out to dinner with my
parents bill clinton and george w
bush that means i had a riveting night
out with my mom my dad and two former
presidents
however if i say i went out to dinner
with my parents bill clinton and george
w
bush that just raises all kinds of
uncomfortable questions like
why weren't my two presidential dads
around for me more growing up i guess
they had a country to run but
still they could have come to at least
one of my baseball games and give me a
ride to school in the marine one
helicopter
i'll tell you the holidays were no
picnic they were extremely
divided i i guess i have some things to
work out with my imaginary parents
anyway
so here's how a missing oxford comma
cost the oakhurst dairy in portland
maine
five million dollars in 2014 truck
drivers for the maine milk and cream
company filed a 10 million dollar
class-action lawsuit alleging oakhurst
had failed to pay them
owed overtime at the time maine law
required time and a half payment
for each overtime hour but it carved out
overtime exceptions for those who
performed the following duties quote the
canning processing preserving freezing
drawing marketing storing packing for
shipment or distribution of agricultural
produce meat and fish products and
perishable
foods so what's the problem here well
the dispute turns on just
one word or in the phrase shipment or
distribution or specifically or in the
absence of an oxford comma
and why does this matter well here's how
npr's colin dwyer explained it back in
2017.
the presence of that tiny conjunction
without a comma as a companion
makes for some muddled meanings is
packing for shipment or distribution
exempt from overtime regulations
or are both packing and shipment and
distribution exempt
these aren't idle questions for the five
delivery drivers who sued oakhurst
because as quartz notes the drivers do
distribute but they do not pack the
perishable foods in other words
one interpretation of the law's list
would make the drivers eligible for
overtime pay the other would mean
they won't get those extra dollars for
extra time on the job so in this lawsuit
the delivery drivers argue that the
quote packing for shipment or
distribution refers to the single
activity of packing
regardless of whether the packing is for
shipment or for distribution
and since the drivers handle perishable
food but do not engage in packing them
they argue that they are not exempt
workers under the law
in response oh curse countered that the
phrase packing for shipment or
distribution
refers to two distinct exempt activities
the first being the
packing for shipment and the second
being distribution since the truckers do
engage in the distribution of dairy
products which are perishable foods
the truckers are exempt from overtime
pay a federal court in maine agreed with
oakhurst ruling that under state law
the drivers were not entitled to
overtime pay and the court concluded
that the main legislature intended to
describe two distinct exempt
opportunities
and there was no dispute that the
truckers do engage in the distribution
of dairy products
but a three-judge panel on the first
circuit court of appeals disagreed and
reversed the lower court's decision
judge david barron opened the 29-page
ruling saying that quote
for want of a comma we have this case
the court reasoned that the lack of an
oxford comma between
shipment and quote or distribution of
meant that both the phrases referred
back to the singular activity of packing
and since the drivers deliver products
but don't pack them they were not
covered by the main exemption for
overtime pay
judge baron concluded that the lack of
akama made the statute ambiguous and
under the rules of interpreting statutes
any ambiguity
must be construed liberally and as a
result the court unanimously sided with
the drivers
sending the case back down to the lower
court and shortly thereafter the party
settled for five
million dollars afterwards the main
legislature stepped in and addressed the
punctuation issue but
i think they might have overcompensated
just a little bit take a look at how the
law is written now the canning semicolon
processing
semicolon preserving semicolon freezing
semicolon
drying semicolon marketing semicolon
storing semicolon packing for shipment
semicolon or distributing of colon
sub one agriculture produce semicolon
sub two meat and fish products semicolon
and
sub three perishable foods period
and when asked about replacing all the
punctuation with semicolons the main
legislature said
no comma all right that takes us to the
third and potentially most important
comma
in history as sir roger caseman said
quote god deliver from such antiquaries
as these to hang a man's life upon a
comma
and throttle him with a semicolon when a
lawyer takes a client's defense
particularly one punishable by death
the best strategy is to force the state
to prove their case and avoid making any
damaging admissions
on your end but that doesn't always go
as planned particularly when you have a
client like sir roger caseman charged
with high treason against england during
world war one not only did he refuse to
deny the underlying charges against him
but sir roger an irish separatist wanted
to give a passionate speech explaining
why his purported treason in the name of
irish independence
was morally justified even during world
war one seeking to prevent his client
from making the state's case for him
sir rogers lawyer in what might have
been a miscalculation of legal strategy
rested his client's defense primarily on
punctuation namely the interpretation of
a comma
in the underlying treason statue and
prior to his arrest for treason roger
kaseman was a highly respected diplomat
described as the father of 20th century
human rights investigations he became
sir roger casement upon being knighted
in 1911
for detailing belgian colonial
atrocities and human rights abuses in
peru
and despite his service to the crown sir
roger was an anti-imperialist irish
separatist
who wanted to see ireland independent
from britain and after being knighted
sir roger became active in
irish republican nationalism in november
1914 just four months after the outbreak
of world war one sir roger negotiated a
formal declaration from germany then
at war with britain pledging that quote
under no circumstances would germany
invade ireland
and germany supported ireland's quest
for quote national prosperity and
national freedom sir roger personally
went to germany to
seek military aid in his quest to gain
irish independence so roger also sought
to persuade irish prisoners of war in
germany to renounce their allegiance to
the king
and form an irish brigade to fight back
against the british but for
collaborating with germany during world
war 1
sir roger casement was arrested and
charged with treason the treason act of
1351
which had been translated into english
from its original norm in french
included the following pertinent text if
a man do levy war against our lord the
king in his realm or be adherent to the
king's enemies in his realm
giving to them aid and comfort in the
realm or elsewhere
etc etc now the defense argued that the
phrase quote or elsewhere applied only
to the words
aid and comfort in the realm but had no
application to the words be adherent to
the king's enemies in the realm or levy
war against our lord
the king in his realm according to this
interpretation the treaty act only
criminalized activities carried out on
british soil
while activities carried out outside of
britain like the ones that sir roger
did in germany did not qualify as
treason under the law the court rejected
this interpretation treating the commas
around aid and comfort like
a parenthetical phrase and the court
concluded that treason was treason
whether committed at home or abroad and
after all of his appeals were exhausted
sir roger casement was hanged in london
in august 1916.
and such was the origin of sir roger's
famous epigram because when
sir roger complained that he was hanged
on a comma he was criticizing his
lawyers losing legal strategy focusing
on punctuation
and not criticizing the statute itself
in lieu of grammatical analysis sir
roger wanted to give a flowery speech
defending his actions to essentially
tell the court
yes i committed treason but i would do
it again if it meant that ireland could
be free
so there you have it legal eagles
grammar and punctuation are
consequential things one misplaced
comment can cost you millions of dollars
or
your life if you're not careful so
remember friends don't let friends draft
ambiguous laws and if you can
be sure to get a designated drafter or
you could regret it for the rest of your
life or at least
until the next legislative session
because otherwise you end up with
questions like
have you eaten grandma the difference
between being courteous to your
grandmother
and trying to be a bloodthirsty cannibal
and as it happens have you eaten grandma
or the life-saving importance of correct
punctuation grammar and good english by
giles brandreth
is one of the many amazing audiobooks
you can listen to on audible but that's
just like
uh my opinion man which is why you could
also listen to the big lebowski and
philosophy by william
irwin on audible i use audible almost
every day it's by far the best source of
audio entertainment on the internet and
if you tried to listen to everything on
audible it would take you
three centuries unless of course you
sped it up which
of course you did so theoretically it's
probably only two centuries worth of
stuff but they recently launched a new
plan called audible plus that gives you
full access to their plus catalog
which is filled with thousands and
thousands of select originals audiobooks
podcast workouts and even guided
meditations and with audible plus you
can download or stream without limit if
you'd like to try audible for free for
30 days just go to audible.com
legaleagle or text legal eagle to 500
500. now
obviously you're not actually going to
text that because this isn't a friggin
podcast
so just click on the link in the
description it's audible.com
legaleagle to get a 30-day free trial to
audible plus
plus clicking on that link in the
description really helps out this
channel
so do you agree with my analysis about
commas leave your objections in the
comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all the videos i've done on the
crazy legal world of legal myths
wacky lawyers and zany trials so click
on this playlist
or i'll see you in court